ce matin aucun élève n'était présent
dans les colles de romenay dès hier les
parents ont été prévenus de la fermeture
de l'établissement
à la sortie de l'école on nous a prévenu
qu' il y avait des cas donc de
démangeaisons non expliqué donc certains
parents sont venus chercher leurs
enfants et on nous a demandé de parents
mener nos enfants le lendemain à l'école
par mesure de précaution les symptômes
sont apparus dans une classe de cm1-cm2
vers la fin de matinée les élèves ont
été victimes de fortes démangeaisons
avec l'apparition de rougeurs évoluant
en cloque sur des parties du corps
l'épidémie s'est ensuite propagé au
cours de la récréation
au final une cinquantaine d'élèves a été
touché aucun enfant n'a été hospitalisés
sont tous rentrés chez eux le soir est
fur et à mesure du temps leur situation
leur état de santé s'améliorait pour
l'instant la cause des démangeaisons
reste inconnu la municipalité attend des
analyses avant de lancer une procédure
de désinfection de l'ensemble des
bâtiments
il faut d'abord savoir quelle est la
cause exacte de céder à mites et puis
ensuite traiter le problème c'est-à-dire
désinfecter les salles savoir d'où ça
vient si il y à des causes extérieures
on ne sait pas pour l'instant on n'a
aucune information
l'école devrait rester fermée jusqu'à
jeudi un service minimum d'accueil sera
mis en place pour les parents n'ayant
pas de solution de garderie